Have you ever shared news online...
...or talked about it with your friends?
Maybe it was something that shocked you or made you laugh,...
...but did you stop to think, is this real?
Fake news is a problem because it can make you believe things...
...that are completely untrue and that could affect how you make important decisions.
A lot of fake news is made up...
...to get you to click on links and share them.
If you do share fake news, people might be making money off of you from advertising.
So how do you know what's real?
Ask yourself.
Has the story been reported anywhere else?
Have you heard of the organization that published it?
Is the story on an official website, for example, ending in .com?
A .com.co website could be unreliable.
Look at the photo, video or story.
Does it look a bit strange to you?
If the answer is yes, maybe it's fake.